شكرا جزيلا لك زين مرحبا بكم في هذه
النافذه اذا للتحليل العسكري اهلا باللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ونبدا معك محمود الكن والعمليات العسكريه
يبدو انها تتركز في جنوب مدينه غزه وغرب
خان يونس هذا صحيح عثمان نحن نشاهد مركز
ثقل للعمليات ما زال مستمرا كما شاهدناه
خلال هذا الاسبوع في نقطتين رئيسيتين
نتحدث عن جنوب مدينه غزه في الشمال في هذه
النقطه اضافه الى غرب خان يونس وجنوب غرب
خان يونس هذا هو مركز ثقل العمليات لكن في
غزه كان هناك تسلسل من
التكتيكات العسكريه في شمال القطاع اذا ما
اتجهنا اليها
هنا سنشاهد بان ا كان هناك مجموعه من
التكتيكات العسكريه سواء بالقصف بالطيران
وحدوث انفجارات في جنوب منطقه غزه هنا حيث
بالقرب من السياج الحدودي اضافه الى
عمليات توغل ومناورات اسرائيليه استمرت
باتجاه الغرب والجنوب الغربي لكن ايضا كان
هناك في المقابل تكتيكات اخرى من الدفاع
هذه التكتيكات شملت الاستهداف بقذائف
الياسين المضاده الدروع اي انها من
الالتحام القريب ايضا هناك التحام او
عمليه قصف مت وسطه بعيده نسبيا باستخدام
قذائف الهاون كانت في مناطق
متفرقه بالقرب من الصبره
والمناطق اللي هنا في قرب الصناعه بالقرب
من الوسط باتجاه الوسط
لكن الارتكاز كان في تل الهواء ومناطق
الشيخ عجلين في هذه النقطه اذا محاولات
مناورات اسرائيليه مره اخرى من الجنوب الى
باتجاه الجنوب الغربي مح حاوله الضغط بهذا
الاتجاه الى الوسط مره
اخرى تعود لتتكرر خلال هذا الاسبوع اضاف
الى ذلك اذا ما توجهنا الى منطقه
الجنوب هنا في خان يونس في غرب خان يونس
ايضا كان هناك استهداف والتحام مع
الدبابات الاسرائيليه استهداف المركا
بقذائف الياسين اضافه الى استخدام عبوات
لاصقه مضاده للدروع هنا سنشاهد ايضا ستظهر
صور اقمار صناعيه نبث لاحقا بان تجمعات
الدبابات الاسرائيليه في غرب خان يونس
تبدو انها تحاول سلوك ال ما يسمى بالشارع
العام في محاوله للضغط من الغرب باتجاه
الوسط هذه كانت هي ابرز العمليات التي
لدينا اليوم عثمان واضح من ان مركز
وتكتيكات العمليات ما زال مستمرا في جنوب
ا غزه في الشمال والجنوب الغربي اضافه الى
غرب خانيونس نعم شكرا لك محمود قراءه اذا
لما ذكره محمود سي اللواء يعني الان
المعارك في شمال قطاع غزه هو مدينه غزه في
الزاويه الجنوبيه الغربيه في تحديدا اي تل
الهواء في ال مربع الجامعات وفي مربع
الامن المركزي وعلى شارع النصر العمليه في
تلك المنطقه هي بحث عن شيء يعني دخلت قوات
جيش الاحتلال الى هذه المنطقه لان توفر
لديها معلومات سواء كانت دقيقه او غير
دقيقه يقال بان هناك من رموز القيادات في
الصف الاول اسمح لي فقط انوه الى الخبر
العاجل وهو هي ان الجزيره سوف تعرض بعد
قليل مشاهد حصلت عليها لمعارك ضاريه بين
كتائب القسام
والقوات الاحتلال اسرائيل وبالتالي الان
هذه القوه حجمها غير محدد لكن هي قوه
مختلطه من لواء نحال واللواء 401 دروع
تبحث عن اهداف دسمه كما يقال او اهداف ذات
قيمه
استراتيجيه اهمها انه يعتقد بان قائد لواء
غزه موجود في تلك المنطقه وبعض قاده
الكتائب ويضاف الى ذلك ان هناك توقع بان
هذه الاماكن لا بد من البحث فيها عن فتحات
انفاق تفضي الى انفاق شبكه الانفاق
العمليات او الانفاق القتاليه وبالتالي
هذه العمليه متوقع ان تستمر لمده اسبوع او
اكثر في تلك المنطقه من اجل البحث عن هذه
الاهداف ما الذي سوف يحدث بعد اسبوع لان
البعض يتحدث عن انسحاب للوحدات
الاسرائيليه بعد اسبوع ربما ولكن هذا ليس
تصريحا رسميا واذا انسحبوا فينسحب لماذا
والى اين الان الان هو دخلت المنطقه
الشماليه في المرحله الثالثه منذ عده
اسابيع وبالتالي هي تدخل للبحث عن اشياء
محدده الان وجدت شبكه الانفاق سيتم
التطوير لم تجد ستنكس وتخرج لانها لا
تستطيع البقاء لانه مقاربه المقاربه
القتاليه
ل كتائب القسام الان فيها شيء من الاختلاف
تعتمد على ما يطلق عليها المجموعات
الصغيره التي تعتمد على اولا الاستطلاع
وتمرير المعلومه وثانيا النار والحركه
وبالتالي اختلف ال طريقه القتال اختلفت عن
الاقتحام الاول عندما كان ثلاثه فرق الان
نتحدث عن قوات محدوده قد تكون مجموعه قتال
قد تكون لواء ناقص جمع لاغراض العمليات
حتى يكون متواجد
اي الدروع ومدعومه بقوات المشاه لانه كما
اشرت لك هي تبحث كان لديها معلومات ان هذه
المنطقه يوجد بها انفاق قتاليه وبالتالي
هنا يدخل
عنصر الوحده الهندسيه المتخصصه بالالغام
ولا بد من وجود عناصر المشاه لتامين
الحمايه للدبابات وبالتالي اذا هي هناك
اشتباكات لا اقول انها اشتباكات سهله او
محدوده لا هناك اشتباكات حقيقيه ونتوقع وج
وصول كما اشرت بعض الفيديوهات غير معروف
حتى هذه اللحظه هل هي من من خان يونس او
من مدينه غزه هذا يتضح خلال وقت قصير جدا
وننوه مره اخرى اذا الجزيره تعرض بعد قليل
مشاهد حصلت عليها لمعارك الضاريه بين
القسام والجيش الاسرائيلي وذلك في شوارع
خان يونس وعلى ذكر خان يونس عند الحديث عن
انتهاء ما يوصف بالعمليات الكبرى ما هي
هذه العمليات الكبرى ما المقصود بذلك
وانتهت اين الان هكذا يقولوا لكن الواقع
الميداني غير الان القتال في خان يونس
ياخذ قطاع دائري تقريبا 270 درجه من اصل
36 60 درجه منذ من من منطقه القراره في
الشمال وياخذ انعطافا الى ابراج الحمد الى
منطقه المواصي الى جوش قطيف الى المخيم
وبالتالي مر عليها اسابيع والقتال محتدم
ولا تستطيع الدخول في عمق مدينه خان يونس
على سبيل المثال ال التشكيل الذي كان
معنيا بمهاجمه المخيم رغم صغر حجمه لم
يستطع ان يدخل وبالتالي سحب قوات واتجه
باتجاه الشمال الغربي ليهاجم من منطقه
الصناعه بينما في الشمال لا يزال يضغط
بقوه وبعنف حتى يستطيع الدخول الى حي
الامل لانه الوصول الى حي الامل يقود
مباشره الى مركز مدينه خانيونس وهو ما
يسعى له لانه يعتبر ان الصيد الرئيس
الثمين موجود في تلك المنطقه وهنا المقصود
القادي السياسيين او العسكريين من الصف
الاول لكتاب القسام وبقيه الفصائل و
الرهائن وبالتالي القتال مستمر محتدم
لكنهم لم يستطيعوا الوصول الى مركز
المدينه بعد في اطراف حي الامل في اطراف
المخيم في اطراف المنطقه الصناعيه نعم
مراسل اذاعه الجيش للشؤون الامنيه
والعسكريه وهو دورون كدوش يقول ان هناك
تقديرات للمسؤولين الكبار في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ترجح القضاء نهائيا على
القدرات الصاروخيه لحماس في غزه وان هذا
يحتاج بين عام الى عامين وحسب تقديراتهم
فحماس لديها ال صاروخ وجميعها مثبته على
منصه اطلاق تحت الارض يواجه الجيش صعوبه
بالوصول اليها فهذان النقطتان النقطه
الكلام عن ان الامر بحاجه الى عام او
عامين ونقطه الحديث عن ان حماس لديها ال
صاروخ الان هناك توجه هناك توجه ان تتحول
الحرب الى ما يطلق عليها حرب الاستنزاف
يعني التخلص من المعارك الحاسمه
وحشد القوه لانه الان يوجد خمسه الويه في
خان يونس يوجد ثلاثه الويه في الوسط
لوائين في الشمال هذا يعني الان حوالي 10
الويه يعني بمعدل ثلاثه فرق وبالتالي هذا
الامر مضني ومكلف فهناك كانت بعض
الاقتراحات حتى من جنرالات متقاعدين لماذا
لا نذهب باتجاه حرب استنزاف نحن نفرضها
نفرض
اليه ادارتها بحيث يتم مهاجمه اي هدف يظهر
وبالتالي في هذه الحاله نستنزف جهد
الفصائل لانها تبقى في حاله جاهزيه مطلقه
ولن يستطيعوا الاستمرار لمده عام او عامين
في الانفاق اذا هي مقاربه طرحت من قبل بعض
المحللين الاسرائيليين لكن القول بانه تم
تفكيك اي قدرات حماس لا تحدثنا كثيرا قبل
ان يعترفوا ولكن قلنا المقاربه استخدام
الصواريخ الان هي ليست المقاربه 7 اكتوبر
نعم اليوم ايضا كان هناك حديث عن اسقاط او
الاستيلاء على طائره تجسس اسرائيليه طائره
التجسس بلا طيار طبعا بدون طيار يا س هذا
اصبح العمل شبه يومي يعني في معظم الايام
يتم اما اسقاط او انزال احدها الط سواء
كانت سكاي او هيرمز او كوات كابتور لانه
هناك
تكثيف استخدام مكثف لهذه الط مشاهد
للطائره طائره هذه الطائره
نعم نعم فيتم اسقاطها والاستيلاء عليها
يبدو انه تم الاستيلاء عليها تم الاستيلاء
لانه عندما تكون بهذا الشكل لا تزال لم
يلحق بها ايه اضرار تكون عمليه انزال وليس
اسقاط لو اسقطت بسلاح يجب ان تتشظى و
يتضرر البدن الرئيسي لها
نعم فنعود للقول اذا ما قالوا ان الوحدات
ستنسحب
فتنسب الى اين تتجه ما زال مطروحا موضوع
رفح يعني انت تحدثت عن هذا الامر كثيرا
ولكن موضوع رفح هذا يتم تكراره كثيرا يعني
بدا التركيز عليه في الايام الماضيه وخاصه
من نتنياهو وكان هناك الحديث يدور ولمده
اسابيع عن محاوله الوصول الى تفاهمات مع
الجانب المصري لكن اي يبدو ان الطلبات
الاسرائيليه غير منطقيه يعني اذا وافقت
عليها مصر كانها تتخلى عن سيادتها وامنها
القومي ومصر لن تتخلى عن سيادتها وامنها
القومي لان هناك معبر فيلادلفيا له وضع
خاص به مليون ف3 الان يتم البحث عن ايجاد
اليه ل اداره معركه رفح لكن السؤال الناس
الموجودين حوالي مليون و300 ال اين
سيذهبوا داخل سيناء لا يوجد اي احتمال اذا
بدي سيتم نقلهم الى منطقه خان يونس معركه
خانيونس لم تنتهي بعد وبالتالي هناك
ضبابيه في في المشهد بصوره عامه لكن الان
يبحث هو جاد بصوره جاده عن حسم معركه
خانيونس ولا اعتقد انه بامكانيه ان يحسمها
ايضا ال يعني هناك مصادر رجحت ان الجيش
اوشك على اتمام احتلاله الى منطقه خان
يونس و وحسب ما نقلته المراسله العسكريه
للاذاعه الرسميه تقديرات الجيش ترجح ان
امامه اسبوعا حتى يحكم سيطرته على المدينه
ومخيم خان خان يونس وينتقل كما تقول هي
الى المرحله الثالثه وانت تقول سيده
اللواء ان المرحله الثالثه قد بدات على كل
حال الان يعني من حيث
المبدا منطقيا في تسلسل العمليات العسكريه
يجب ان ينهي معركه خان يونس السؤال
المطروح هل يستطيع انهاء معركه خان يونس
هذا هو السؤال وبالتالي هذا هو المحور لن
يستطيع انهاء معركه خان يونس لماذا لانه
القوات المتواجده لواء خان يونس يعتبر
اللواء الاكبر والاقوى والاشرس مقاتلي
مقاتلي النخب نخب نخب المقاتلين من
الفصائل الاخرى موجودين في منطقه محافظه
خان يونس لا اتحدث عن المدينه في منطقه
محافظه خانيونس وبالتالي ليس بالسهوله
لننظر الى المنطقه الشرقيه عبسان عبسان
خزاعه الزنه بن سهيله هذه المنطقه شبه
توقفت العمليات كعمليات رئيسيه لماذا لانه
لم يستطع ان يحقق اي انجاز في هذه المنطقه
فهو بحث عن مقاربه جديده وعمل حركه
الالتفاف المزدوج من الشمال ومن الجنوب
ليدخل مدينه غزه من الجهه الغربيه
لاعتقاده ان الخطه الدفاعيه في تلك
المنطقه هي اضعف منها في الوجه لدينا
دقيقه الى اي مدى هذه المرحله حاسمه في
هذه الحرب الايام الايام المقبله انا قلت
منذ بدات المعركه هذه معركه كسر عظم من
يكسبها سيسجل انتصار و يعتد انتصار يعتد
به اذا حزمت لصالح جيش الاحتلال سيكون
نتنياهو يقول الان صدقتم كلامي
بانني كنت اتحدث بالحقيقه المجرده بينما
اذا لم يستطع واستطاعت قسام وهذا ما
اتوقعه ان تفشل الهجوم سيبقى موقفه
اي متارجح وتبقى المقاومه صامده وقادره
على على الاستمرار اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك وشكرا ايضا لمحمود الكن الذي كان معنا
على الخارطه التفاعليه ختام هذه النافذه
الخاصه بالتحليل العسكري لهذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه نعود الى جمال ريان
في غرفه الاخبار عثمان